what's going on guys you will not
believe this Deathstroke was almost
Superman in the DC EU is a crazy story
if you're new to the channel I do Marvel
and DC every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything and leave all your
requests in the comments below
but Deathstroke Joe Manganiello we all
went crazy when they dropped that teaser
last year if you haven't seen it here it
is there's no audio for it but this is
him doing a costume test so awesome
can't wait to see him kick Batman's ass
during the Batman solo movie even though
some of that's in question based on
recent events which I will explain at
the end of the video but the Superman
story is nuts so I'm gonna play this
interview that he did where he explains
all the steps he went through and how he
was getting ready to put that costume on
and now it's come full circle that he's
back in the DC EU what was there an
angry phone call when you found out that
you True Blood for whatever reason and
it's not whatever reason like it was
legitimately they couldn't let you out
they needed you but they said sorry we
can't even let you test for this we can
even let you have meet with Zack was
that I met with Zack you did meet was
that I had an hour and a half long
meeting with Zack which is what was
causing all the trouble I went ahead
I met with casting and then they brought
me over to Zack I met with all the
producers I met with John Josh nee and
Thomas tall at legendary you got some
real stuff going you know I met
everybody yeah everybody involved and
then sat and then finally sat down with
Zack for an hour and a half and had a
big conversation about the character and
where it was going and etc and then they
called the True Blood costume shop for
my measurements to build my suit and
that's what caused the that's that's
when it's thought that was put to a to
an end and how was how was Joe then when
he when you learn that did you like have
some talk with Alan and HBO and
everybody and trying I mean I mean on my
agent Kevin you vane said I'm not sure
if I can get this done or if I can work
this out but if I can't do it no one can
sir what's your work at Time Warner who
owns Warner Brothers Studios and HBO
they're the umbrella over the top of
them so we've got wall
okay at least we've got that in our
favor yeah yeah and there was just
nothing that could be done and at that
point you lay in bed for a week and
stare at the ceiling and and you then
have to get into a place of gratitude
for this job my day job which did the
show which was the reason why I was
noticed in the first place Zach and his
wife watch True Blood and I guess when I
walked out he said that guy be a great
Superman this was you know years ago you
know a year to year before I wound up in
his office so you have to be grateful
for that
it was also you know the first steady
paycheck I had in a long time it was a
great job of the hottest show in the
world at that time yeah so if the put it
in perspective yeah you put it in
perspective and you get back in there
like you know good soldier and you go
back to work and you don't let it affect
you did you did you just tough sometimes
did you take a little time before seeing
Man of Steel was it tough for you
eventually to see it you know I wouldn't
see it I couldn't I just couldn't I was
really you know I'm a sensitive guy and
I was kind of rocked by the whole thing
and I had bicep surgery after Magic Mike
too and I was up in the middle of the
night because like you know with the
pain and I was on painkillers and it was
on all right let's go
so I'd even think about it you're gonna
be playing a jet stroke in the new
Batman which is a bad guy yeah it's you
to an extent to an extent I mean you
know that the character of Deathstroke
is very specific you know there's he's
but I mean the building of that
character is very similar I mean there's
I think you know looking at someone as
evil or a villain is really not accurate
because they think they think they're
heroes
well well they've been a they've been
affected in a certain way and I mean you
could look at a character like Batman
for example Batman had this you know
this tragedy this personal tragedy he
lost these loved ones and swore this
would never happen to anyone else again
right and became the civilian lanty with
very questionable tactics at times you
know on the
converse if you read the comic books
Deathstroke is a character that's not
dissimilar to that origin story he lost
a loved one it was a you know and rather
than swearing it would never happen to
anyone again there was like a bit of
like numbness that I think or or you
know he kind of his change was that he
became this assassin for hire hmm and
wound up being fine with just murdering
everyone inside for the right price
right so you know there's a very fine
line between those two characters and I
think if either one crossed that that
line they would turn into the other very
easily so it's almost this mirror
reflection of what you know those
choices could have been for Bruce Wayne
had he gone a different direction and I
think a lot of the Christopher Nolan
movies especially kind of explore like
is he crossing the line right is this
actually too much yeah so you know in my
mind I mean there's you know you could
say though that strokes a villain but I
mean there's there's definitely a way to
look at him that way but there's a way
to look at him as you know an antihero
right or just someone who's figuring
things out in his own way or trying to
work something out over the course of
this two-hour movie not unlike a red
dragon born a little person that's how
much freedom do you have if you're
playing a comic book character that has
a back story that's been told throughout
how much freedom do you have to put your
own spin on these characters um that's a
good question I think it's probably you
know level up Shelley I think it's you
know it's case-by-case you know in in
and you know the the real answer is like
you know we'll see once we get on the
ground but you know I'm somebody that
likes to start preparing way ahead of
time and so you know I've read almost
all the comic books and involved
involving involving him just to get the
information out
but some of them are useful some of them
are not gonna be useful because
ultimately the the script is my that's
my text and and I have to play that but
like I started katana trading recently
like a live sword training and I started
meeting with you know various martial
arts teachers and discussing with them
ok so you know what are like the most
offensive styles of martial arts ones
where you're not waiting for someone to
attack you but ones where you're looking
to make the attack and then what are the
most deadly ones where are the scrolls
you know the ancient you know the old
Japanese scrolls that have these really
deadly techniques you don't teach to the
average student on the street something
that only somebody who would go looking
for it that are really weren't bad you
know or dangerous like what are those ok
so now what are the stances what are
some like really unorthodox stances that
someone who learned say ninjutsu would
stand in okay now what if that person
lost an eye if that person lost an eye
how would they then change the alter of
the stance so that you would have a
better peripheral vision what would that
look like you know and so then you start
cooking and then you start building a
story kind of I guess outside in that's
like a very physical way to build this
story yeah but then you know on the
other side of it like I said I mean I'm
looking at the script rather than the
comic books I mean the columns are
giving me a good general kind of area of
what we're talking about of where this
character is located but the script
that's really like you know because they
might change the can and they might you
know there's there's been I think like
three or four different waves that he's
lost his eye okay well which you know
are we doing one of those are we doing a
completely new way I need to play that
such a crazy story can you just imagine
Wolfman Joe Manganiello playing Superman
he's got the body for it he's got the
physicality and I think that he's a
great actor but I think things worked
out for the better one because villains
just have a lot more fun so I think
he'll have a lot more fun playing
Deathstroke going up against the heroes
sometimes it can be a curse to be such a
big character like Superman that just
follows you around for the rest of your
life and if you are not an amazing
Superman that's what everybody will
remember oh hey that's the guy that
ruins Superman it'll just follow you
around for the rest
you're alive so he gets to be a villain
have way more fun and just Boba Fett the
[ __ ] out of Batman through the DC EU and
all the other heroes so the big thing
that's changed now though is that he's
like well I think that I'm still in the
Batman solo movie because Matt Reeves
took over he has the power to rewrite
the script so in the Jeff Jones Ben
Affleck version Deathstroke was the main
villain so that could change a little
bit but I think it's just so iconic and
he's such a big character that he'll
still be in there even though whatever
the story is going to be is gonna change
a little but let me know what do you
guys think about Joe Manganiello playing
Superman they just be so crazy big
coincidence - is that like after all
this news broke that Zack Snyder posted
this picture of Henry Cavill and his
very first costume test which was
actually the Christopher Reeve costume
he totally looks the part so I do think
that it's the right call but I think
it's funny that he posted this saying
you know Henry was my first choice for
Superman right after this Joe
Manganiello story broke so I know a lot
of you been asking for more Justice
League Darkseid videos so what I'll do
is there was a really cool Steppenwolf
thing that drops so I'll do a video for
that he was talking a lot about his
character there are some changes from
the comics so I'll explain that that
should post in the next couple of days
but there's a whole bunch of Star Wars
they'll probably some new Rick and Morty
but leave all your video requests in the
comments below and if you haven't seen
that you can check here for like really
awesome behind the scenes Darth Vader
Castle stuff from Star Wars and learn
all about last Jedi trailer stuff
happening next week and you can click
here for brand new flash season 3 thank
you so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video